the house about the success last night
of the House of Commons teams in the tug
of war
[Music]
so let's just now start with questions
to Deputy Prime Minister David Johnson
question number one prime minister
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker I have been asked
to reply my right honorable friends the
prime minister is in Washington at the
invitation of President Biden they will
be discussing cooperation on a range of
issues including Ai and global trade and
of course continuing our leadership in
galvanizing international support for
the people of Ukraine Mr Speaker this
week is carers week I know that
colleagues across the house will wish to
join me in paying tributes to the huge
contribution on paid carers make to our
society Mr Speaker this morning I had
meetings with ministerial colleagues and
others in addition to my duties in this
house I shall have further such meetings
later today David Jones thank you Mr
Speaker at the election the labor party
committed to abolishing SATs Academy
Schools and ofsted three policies given
to them by an education Union that also
opposed this government's use of phonics
and yet thanks to this government's use
and focus on Phonics English primary
school children have just been ranked
the best readers in Europe
yeah yeah so does my right honorable
friend agree with me this is another
example of why on this side of the house
we have quality to meet the needs of
children rather than meet the demands of
trade unions
it won't surprise my honorable friends
to hear that I absolutely agree with him
driving up literacy rates is Central to
our plan to grow the economy so I'm
delighted at those latest figures
showing that children in England are the
best readers in the western world and
why is that Mr Speaker because since
2010 we've raised the number of schools
rated good or outstanding by nearly 30
percent and the verdict is clear only
the conservatives can be trusted with
our children's future
Deputy leader of the opposition Angela
Reyna
hey Mr Speaker speaking of the last
election the Tory Manifesto promised to
end the abuse of the judicial review
how's it going
well I I welcome the much shorter
question from the writer of a lady today
let me just remind the right honoral
lady of a few facts about the covert
inquiry we set up the covert inquiry we
have provided it with more than 55
000 documents so far we have given it
all the financial resources it needs so
that we can learn the lessons from the
pandemic but Mr Speaker in Wales they
also had a pandemic and what have the
labor run Wales authorities done there
no independent inquiry in Wales
as ever one rule for labor and another
for everyone else
yeah it's like it's pretends that it's
complicated but it's simple they felt
the inquiry to get to the truth then
block that inquiry from getting the
information that it need us for and now
they're taking it to court I know he
considers himself among other people so
using his vast knowledge of working
class Britain does he think working
people will thank him for spending
hundreds of thousands of pounds of their
money on loophole lawyers just so that
they government can obstruct the covert
inquiry
prime minister well we will provide the
inquiry with each and every document
related to covid including all internal
discussions in any form as requested
while crucially protecting what is Holy
and unambiguously irrelevant because
essentially the right honorable lady is
calling for years worth of documents and
messages between named individuals to be
in scope and that Mr Speaker could cover
anything from civil servants medical
conditions to intimate details about
their families but I really will say to
the right honorable lady I find it
extraordinary that she should lecture us
on value for money for the taxpayer
when I understand she has now purchased
two pairs of noise canceling headphones
on expenses
fair I will be fair to the right
honorable lady
if I had to attend Shadow cabinet
meetings I think I'd want to tune them
out too
the
Deputy Prime Minister was very good
saying he was welcoming short questions
I'd also welcome Charter answers
asked for and across the world covered
inquiries are well underway while his
government hides information and shells
out public money on legal bills for the
Oxbridge one the former prime minister
is now demanding another million to pay
for his new lawyers now I know the
honorable gentleman and his former boss
has fallen out and maybe he wants to
patch things up but can he seriously say
this is a good use of taxpayers money
Deputy Prime Minister I if we want to
talk about relationships between between
different people I don't think we need
to search her WhatsApp messages to know
that there's no communication between
her and the leader of her party
and I will happily happily stand up for
our record on covid because when she and
her party were carping from the
sidelines calling for longer lockdowns I
was working as culture secretary to keep
our football clubs running to protect
our theaters and museums and deliver the
largest cultural recovery package in the
western world that's the difference
between her and me Mr Speaker while she
was collecting titles I was getting on
with a job
Angel Elena
Mr Speaker no for the last couple of
years he's been trying to prep p.m Prime
Ministers for this but these punch lines
of dire he really needs to go back to
school himself
and speaking of school
thousands of children are missing from
school absence has nearly doubled since
before the pandemic the Prime Minister
says he's maxed out on his support for
school pupils but why did the government
abandon its plans for a register of
missing children
the Prime Minister
well on the specifics of the writing or
ladies question that is not the case and
we continue to keep the policy under
review and what I would say is I am
I am very proud of this government's
record on funding and support for
schools four billion pounds more this
year four billion pounds next year and
the result of all of that investment is
we have the highest standards of reading
in the entire Western World what a
contrast from when the party offers it
we're in power
Angela Reyna
so there we have it Mr Speaker thousands
of children missing under review still
so let me ask him about another uh
something else that's gone missing the
Public Accounts committee this week
revealed that the government's fraud
increased fourfold with ministers
overseeing the loss of 21 billion pounds
of taxpayers money in the last two years
can he tell us how much of our money
they expect to recover
that the prime minister
well Mr Speaker we are working
tirelessly to recover those funds and
have made and we have made huge progress
already but again if the party opposite
wants to talk about wants to talk about
good use of taxpayers money what do we
have from the party opposite
plans for an unfunded 28 billion pounds
spending spree and what would that do
drive up borrowing push up interest
rates adding a thousand pounds to
everyone's mortgage Mr Speaker I know
they're out of touch but even she must
realize that Britain cannot afford labor
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Britain can't afford any more
of the conservatives
seems to have lost count the answer is a
quarter only a quarter of the billions
of pounds of taxpayers money lost to
fraud is expected to be clawed back if
this government can't get the public
money back they can't be trusted with
anything else it's become a pattern of
behavior from the conservatives and an
inquiry missing the evidence schools
missing their pupils taxpayers missing
their money and ministers missing in
action and all the while working people
pay the price for their mistakes this
week the Public Accounts committee also
warned that this epic fraud and waste
could happen all over again due to the
ministers living in denial of the facts
if it's government can't admit the truth
then how on Earth can they learn the
lessons
[Music]
well I would say to the riding lady
we're actually putting more resources in
throughout this year to tackle fraud and
error and we continue to make real
progress with it but again it's quite
extraordinary from the from the from the
party opposite well we are working to
drive down inflation and energy bills
what's what's the right order of a lady
doing receiving 10 000 pounds from just
stop oil backers
adopting their policies backing
protesters blocking new production and
forcing us to import more foreign oil
and gas do you know what for once Mr
Speaker I find myself in agreement with
the GMB Union
what did they say
they save lacks intellectual rigor and
could decimate communities just like
labor
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker the the latest
Roots update for East West rail has
recently been published and
unfortunately the link to Aylesbury is
still just a dotted line on the map now
I've raised the need for this vital
income several occasions in the house
because it'll cut congestion on our road
it'll stimulate the economy and it will
reduce air pollution each time I've been
asked to work with stakeholders to
reduce the cost I'm really pleased to
say we've managed to do that there is
now a much cheaper proposal on the table
so can my ride humble friend now please
change that dotted line into a solid
line and give my constituents the
railway they do want
I know my honorable friend is an
absolutely tireless campaigner for this
project and I can assure him that the
department for transport is working with
network rail and the East West rail
company to consider the feasibility of
lower cost Railway links on the
Aylesbury spur and I know that he will
continue to make that case very very
vigorously we now come to the deputy
leader of the SMP Murray black
thank you Mr Speaker when the Prime
Minister took office he said he would
genomics develop
ER confidence at the heart of this
government today UK interest rates are
one of the highest in the G20 and
mortgage rates are rising nearly back to
where they were after the former PM
crashed the economy is it not the case
that this government's biggest
achievement is that they're trashing the
economy just a wee bit slower than the
predecessor
[Music]
I don't know whether the honorable lady
had been following the news today but
actually again the oecd upgraded our
growth forecasts
and really
[Applause]
one month ago
I the home nation came together
celebrating that wonderful moment of
Pomp pageantry and pride in our nation
and what did the right what did The
Honorable lady describe it as I quote I
quote Mr Speaker a pantomime well the
real pantomime is the SNP in Scotland
no they're black
I don't know what question the Deputy
Prime Minister was asking but let me try
another one the government plans this
government plans to cut taxes for the
richest spend six billion pounds
imprisoning people fleeing war and
persecution and has lost 21 billion
pounds to governments fraud fraud
throughout this pandemic is the view
from the prime minister's luxury
helicopter so skewed that during a cost
of living crisis he thinks this is what
people's priorities are
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm going to take no lectures on
profligacy from the from from the SNP
and actually what
what is it that this government has done
we
provided record increases the personal
allowance meaning that a person working
full-time on the minimum wage has seen a
thousand pound reduction in their tax
well Ben's
has many vibrant small shops at the
Beating Heart of the economy but Saint
Ann's Town Center has got fantastic
potential but it's layout quite frankly
is becoming tired investment is needed
to reinvigorate the town center better
connecting it to the seafront and
reinvigorate the tone what steps am I
right honorable friend taking it's
getting you this government's leveling
up mission to deliver for towns like
Saint Anne's
well that's precisely why we've created
the leveling up fund and there's 3.6
billion pounds within that in the
townsfund to be invested in high streets
up and down the country and we will be
outlining the third round of submissions
to that fund and I'm quite sure my
honorable friend will make a very
vigorous case for his constituency for
funding during that round uh David
speaker yesterday I met Karen Karen is a
carer for her husband Alan
who has Parkinson's and Louis body
dementia
Karen told me how hard it is to get
people with power just to listen to her
like so many carers Karen feels her
caring work just isn't valued at times
she's wanted to give up but knows she
must carry on because of her husband
Mr Speaker remarkable carers like Karen
save the government more than the entire
NHS budget
so will the government finally recognize
the value of Britain's family carers and
not just pay tribute to them
but give them the financial and
practical support they deserve
Deputy Prime Minister well of course I
would like to join the right on a
gentleman in paying tribute to Karen and
to hard-working unpaid carers up and
down the country and I know the right on
a gentleman speaks from personal
experience about this as well we have
provided 2.3 billion pounds worth of
support for social care an additional 25
million committed to putting people at
the heart of care in the heart of care
white paper and 327 million pounds is
also committed to the better care fund
Alberto Costa thank you Mr Speaker many
of my constituents are deeply concerned
about the proposals for the 440 acre
Hinckley national rail free interchange
and the impact that this proposed site
has on the environment and for example
an infrastructure like narborough
railway station now I know the Deputy
Prime Minister cannot talk about an
individual planning application that is
for central government to make but can
he give an assurance to to my South
leicestershire constituents to blaby
District Council like counselor Ben
Taylor counselor Maggie Wright Terry
Richardson Mike Shirley and others that
the voice of my constituents will be
here in this planning application prime
minister well I know from the the
vigorous campaigning of The Honorable
gentleman that his constituent's voice
has been and will be heard as he knows I
can't comment on individual cases what I
can say Mr Speaker is I have experience
of this in my own constituency as well
and I know what a blight can be provided
by those rail Freight projects so I do
have every Sympathy for the case that he
is making
yeah thank you Mr Speaker the Deputy
Prime Minister this week we had plans
for two Universal basic income pilots in
England there have been similar schemes
planned for Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland with the progress of the gig
economy and the acceleration of
artificial intelligence it's clear that
the working environment will need
drastically overhauled will this
government waken up to the reality of
the situation and instruct both the DWP
and hmrc to engage with these Pilots so
we can constructively assess the pros
and cons and what to safeguard unless
precarious future for the Next
Generation yeah every prime minister
well Mr Speaker the government and I
have never been convinced about the case
for a universal basic income we're not
alone in that it's also the position of
Paul Johnson at the ifs I think a much
better solution is to create more jobs
which this government has done and cut
taxes on working people which is what
this government has done that is the
route for prosperity for people up and
down the country
thank you uh Mr Speaker revitalizing old
way regenerating Our Town centers and
helping tour Bay's high-tech sector to
grow would deliver leveling up for
Torbay what expectations does he have
with the new leveling up partnership in
focusing government effort and resources
on doing this
Deputy Prime Minister well as as I'm
sure my honorable friend knows that
leveling up Partnerships are committed
to work hand in hand with 20 places
across England in most need of that
leveling up they're backed by 400
million pounds worth of investment and I
know that my honorable friend will make
the case most robustly for funding for
his constituency the worst thank you
very much Mr Speaker after 13 years the
government has repeatedly broken its
promise to repair social care post
pandemic I've been visiting sheltered
housing schemes in hornsey and wood
green and Time After Time basic Services
Dentistry Podiatry befriending are all
missing will the government take urgent
action and repair this mess or will it
be down to labor again to pick up the
pieces
well for the NHS as a whole this
government has provided record
additional funding and indeed since we
came to power in 2010 funding is up 70
billion pounds and in addition in
respect of social care the my writer and
friend the chancellor has provided a
further 2.3 billion pounds worth of
support to this vital sector
yeah I congratulate the government for
its determination to bring forward the
rollout of electronic patient records
for everyone in England and can I ask my
right honorable friend to confirm that
this gives us a brilliant opportunity to
roll out the digital version of the red
book that is so transformational for
every family and giving their baby the
best start for life
every prime minister I totally agree
with my writing rent and I I know what a
tireless campaign that she has been on
this issue both in and out of government
and yes I am I'm happy to confirm that
the so-called digital red book will be
rolled out and we expect it to be
delivered over the course of the next
two years
thank you very much Mr Speaker the
Deputy Prime Minister likes to call
himself Mr normal he went to our normal
school and he understands normal people
we know that normal people are
struggling in their story cost of living
crisis people like nurses who he said
had unreasonable wage demands this is
the same person who on top of his 154
000 pound salary charged two businesses
over 13 Grand for just 20 hours work
that's 670 pounds per hour does Mr
Lauren will really think is worth 65
times abandon us
I'm not quite sure what the the question
was aiming at but what I can say to the
well
oh gentleman is that
is as provided over 3 000 pounds worth
of support to help people through the
cost of living and why have we been able
to do that thanks to the strength of our
economy and the strength of our Union
and what's happening in Scotland the SMP
government are putting taxes up on
ordinary hard-working people like
Drummond thank you very much Mr Speaker
and we're all concerned about the 81 000
children that are not in the school
register and under the term home
educated and no one not local
authorities all schools can honestly
answer the question how many children
are not in school therefore how can we
know that every child is safe and
suitably educated these children are out
of sight and out of mind the Secretary
of State for Education have said that
this is one of her priorities as had the
education select committee so can I ask
my right on the friend to expedite my
10-minute rule Bill to place a duty on
local authorities to maintain a register
of children who are not in school so
that we can ensure that every child is
visible safe suitably educated and
receiving the supports enable them to
thrive yeah
Mr Speaker we do want to ensure that all
children are safe and have access to an
excellent education and of course local
authorities must seek to identify
children missing in their area and
ensure that they are safe the department
for Education continues to undertake
work to support Swift identification and
greater support of children missing in
education
speaker well in spite of government spin
to the contrary the backlog of
undetermined initial Asylum claims has
risen even since December from 160 000
to 170 000 plus caseworker numbers are
down returns are still down so will the
Deputy Prime Minister agree to meet me
to hear my constituents concerns about
the home secretary's plans to commandeer
yet another hotel the study Park in the
village of furnace and explain what more
he will do to speed up clearing the
backlog so as to return people to Safe
countries settle genuine refugees and
avoid the need to use Australia Park
Hotel
Deputy Prime Minister this government
will take whatever action is necessary
both to clear the backlog and to stop
the boats and actually as she may have
heard from the right my right of a
friend the Prime Minister small boat
arrivals to the UK are actually down 20
this year our French deal has prevented
33 000 illegal Crossings this year
Albanian arrivals are down 90 we've
removed 1 800 albanians we've increased
the number of illegal working raids and
the Legacy Asylum backlog is now down 20
percent give me more thank you Mr
Speaker Samina hollywell a 12 year old
girl in my constituency suffered an
horrific ordeal she tragically then went
on to take her own life she was let down
by the system this is this week is the
two-year anniversary of her death
labor-controlled Sefton Council have
still gotten inadequate rating from
ofsted for children's social care so
will my writable friend meet with me to
discuss what further measures can be
taken to better protect children in
Southport and The Wider Council area
Deputy Prime Minister
I congratulate my honorable friend for
for raising what I'm sure members on
both sides of this house would agree is
a heartbreaking case and I know that all
our thoughts will be with Samina her
family and her friends all children of
course have the right to be safe and
protected I understand that the
department for Education will shortly
begin Consulting on strengthening
statutory guidance to ensure Health
agencies police forces and councils work
together more collaboratively and end
decision that puts children's needs that
prevent putting children's needs at the
heart of their work of course I'm very
happy to meet with the honorable
gentleman and for the health department
ministers to meet with him also Hillary
Ben thank you very much indeed Mr
Speaker Huntington's disease eventually
Rob suffers of their ability to walk
talk eat care for themselves and make
decisions it changes the person they
were and has a 50 chance of being
inherited by their children will the
government back the Huntington's disease
communities call for better access to
Mental Health Services a care
coordinator in every area and specific
nice guidelines so that everyone
affected by this devastating condition
can get the help they need
I completely agree with the right on
gentleman about the devastating impact
of this terrible disease it is the case
that we have increased significantly
investment in investment in mental
health I of course am happy to arrange
for Department of Health ministers to
meet with him to discuss this further
Simon Baines thank you Mr Speaker
Wales is the land of song and there is
no better example of this than John's
boys Male Chorus from gross included
science who have performed magnificently
in the recent series of Britain's Got
Talent moving Bruno Tonioli and the
other judges to tears with the Deputy
Prime Minister join with me in
congratulating in the choir and also the
other many Community choirs included
South and across the UK who bring such
pleasure to the singers and audiences
alike
[Applause]
well I I would actually argue that um
choral music is possibly one of our
greatest contributions to Global culture
and I really do join my honorable friend
in congratulating John voy's Male Chorus
for their fantastic achievements in
reaching the semi-final of Britain's Got
Talent and I'm sure that they will
continue to entertain and engage
communities for many years to come
follow Barker
host of anti-corruption champion has
been vacant for over a year does the
decracy Prime Minister think the vacancy
increases or decreases the risk of
corruption in government
Deputy Prime Minister well in my
department the the cabinet office I'm
working very closely with my writer and
friend the paymaster general we are
taking extensive steps to make sure we
crack down on fraud and ways to make
sure that procurement is transparent and
of course we will be filling that
vacancy very shortly
yeah yeah thank you Mr Speaker the
government do not have any money of
their own every penny they spend is
taxpayers money including money spent
supporting the economy during the
pandemic so in that light would my right
honorable friend agree with me that it
would be disgraceful for a political
party to accept huge donations from a
company that will simultaneously
claiming hundreds of thousands of pounds
of public support during further
I of course completely agree with my
honorable friends and actually the the
scheme the furlough scheme helped
protect around 4 14.6 million jobs
during that terrible covert crisis but
what do we discover Labor's taking 1.5
million from just stop oil backers
adopting their policy to block new oil
and gas it's job destroying recklessness
and it's hard-working people
unfortunately Mr Speaker who will be
left paying the price Ashley Dalton
speaker in West Lancashire my
constituents are concerned about their
children's education and specifically
the ongoing long-term impact of covid-19
restrictions on their children's
educational development now a Public
Accounts committee report out today
finds that the department for education
is failing to take fast and effective
recovery action to close the attainment
gap in schools and the department has
admitted that it will take a decade 10
years just to get the education
attainment Gap back to pre-pandemic
levels so when will the government stop
blaming everyone else and take
responsibility for failing a generation
of lost learners
[Applause]
actually before covid struck the
attainment gap between disadvantaged
peoples and their peers had narrowed in
both primary and secondary schools under
this government since covert struck
we've provided almost 5 billion pounds
in education recovery and I would say to
The Honorable lady if she's that
concerned about children's education she
should be calling on the education
unions to call off their damaging
strikes
thank you very much indeed Mr Speaker
mortby Town Council and will be main FC
who play at the miners Recreation ground
I'll fight you to make sure the ground
is financially sustainable and can stay
open but sizzra who run it has a history
of selling off on profitable areas
developers will not allow a full bar to
be open and provide much needed Capital
which has a sport of a council residence
space is a lot of recreation grounds are
important parts by mining Heritage so
can my right honorable friend step in to
help multi-main get the bar that it
needs and to help secure the financial
future of this ground to sure it does
not face the same group fate as the
demons from the miners welfare
Recreation ground Deputy Prime Minister
well may I offer my strongest support to
my honorable friends uh campaign I think
he's absolutely right to raise it I do
question the the extent of my powers to
intervene on a bar closure in his
constituency but I will certainly
examine what we could do further
thank you very much Mr Speaker the East
West rail announcement proposes a
six-track route which will impact at
least 66 properties in Bedford including
the demolition of 37 homes so will the
Deputy Prime Minister tell me why
resident concerns have been ignored and
really give me a commitment today that
if the majority of the residents are
against the plan in the statutory
consultation his government will not
approve the proposal
Deputy Prime Minister of course we will
engage with local communities but I do
find it rather OD that
deposit have been saying for the past
few months about how they want to build
more housing build more infrastructure
and then as soon as there is a proposal
to do so which will enormously enrich
that area it's being opposed
it's real but ill thank you Mr Speaker
the Deputy Prime Minister will know that
the calling of an early election in
Spain has caused some concern about
delay to achieving a treaty between the
United Kingdom and the European Union in
relation to Gibraltar will he confirm
that it Remains the policy of Her
Majesty's government to prioritize
achieving such a treaty once the outcome
of the election is known and that the
government will do all of these
necessary to secure that treaty for the
benefit of Gibraltar and its Spanish
neighbors and to give all the necessary
support to Gibraltar and its British
people for their future security and
prosperity
Liberty prime minister well I can assure
my honorable friends that the United
Kingdom and his Majesty's governments
remain steadfast in its support for
Gibraltar and I can assure my honorable
friend that we are working side by side
with the government of Gibraltar and we
remain committed to concluding that UK
EU treaty as soon as possible final
question for Allison thank you Mr
Speaker today the oecd have said that
the UK is on course to have the higher
rate of rate of inflation than almost
all of the other G20 countries its
families in Putney and up or down the
country who will be suffering because of
this will the Deputy Prime Minister
finally commit to introducing a proper
windfall tax on the enormous profits of
the oil and gas giants and take pressure
off struggling households
everybody prime minister well we've we
actually introduced a bigger windfall
tax than the labor party were proposing
thanks to that 75 windfall tax last
winter we paid half of people's energy
bills and she talks about the oecd what
she failed to mention was that the oecd
today gave the highest upgrade of growth
to the United Kingdom compared to any
other country
these questions